murder rape and conscripting children as
soldiers offenses committed by booze
Kunta ganda that along with other war
crimes have led to him being sentenced
to three decades in prison he ordered
fighters to carry out attacks in Italy
province over two years in 2002 and 2003
to drive out one ethnic community judges
are the International Criminal Court in
The Hague described his involvement in
atrocities carried out by rebel soldiers
as substantial poorab of civilians as a
crime against humanity and as a war
crime 28 years for murder and attempting
attempted murder as a crime against
humanity and as a war crime 30 years for
persecution as a crime against humanity
30 years of imprisonment agonda was
called The Terminator by people in
eastern Democratic Republic of Congo the
crimes committed by the patriotic force
for the liberation of Congo rebel group
included murder sexual violence and the
sexual slavery of female child soldiers
one as young as nine in tuganda led the
military wing Thomas Lubanga was a head
of the group and is serving 14 years in
jail at the ICC this man says his two
brothers were killed by the fighters we
lost many family members sisters
brothers uncles we also lost a lot of
properties eatery might be the focus of
in taganas case but in another town more
than 800 kilometers south victims of a
moussaka where a hundred and fifty
people were killed in one day in 2006
have been following court proceedings
Kinley they claim tuganda was one of the
leaders of rebel fighters who attacked
their villages in Kwanza and was in
charge of the killings
almost everyone here in Tianjin lost a
loved one those we talked to said Bosco
Ntaganda and the fighters he led accuse
them of protecting a rival rebel group
they also say they want justice they
were born akhirin i'm totin Rebecca you
may choose as huskar
she says her husband and one-year-old
son were killed in evidence what's
happening within tuganda should be a
deterrent to others who want to come and
terrorize us in the villages those
people destroyed our lives in tuganda is
the fourth person to be convicted by the
ICC do the South paw in it Tory says he
deserves to be in jail for life
Rebecca Newman khawaja is still waiting
for her justice Katherine soil
al-jazeera ki-hwan ja is the Democratic
Republic of Congo